[Music]
okay I have beef I have beef with the
internet and its dislike of nice things
every so often I will see these types of
videos that hate on Specialized
containers and look I don't personally
own anything like this so I don't really
have any skin in the game but are we
just going to act like any purchase in
existence is dumb if it's purely for
Aesthetics like how hard is it to
imagine that that lady might just like
the way that cute little dryer sheet
container looks better than a branded
cardboard box that it comes in do people
also get confused when people buy cool
skins for the PS5 or whatever like Ju
Just let people have nice things